ladies and gentlemen please welcome our
hometown hero
joe musgrove
joe musgrove
we welcome your family and your
girlfriend erica here
and we want to thank you for bringing
history to san diego last friday night
after
eight thousand
two hundred and six games the padres
have a no-hitter
brought to us by a native son ryan
weathers takes the field for the padres
and
the padres taking the field tonight
against the la dodgers and we saw him
first against the dodgers in the
postseason now he faces them tonight
donnie when he made his major league
debut in the playoffs he was pitching
and he had the attitude like he had been
around for five six years he took that
baseball he threw strike one his dad was
quoted saying you know what he's a
strike thrower and his first pitch in
the big leagues it was in the playoffs
it was a strike and the padres and
dodgers meet for the first time
of 19. round one
and the pitch to seeger is grounded to
the left side manny's there little flip
tatis onto first low hosmer handles
double play
five to six to three looked a little
awkward because of the shift but
fernando did a good job coming over to
second base and a great scoop by hosmer
at first two away
they face walker bueller
a couple of years to find his last
losing decision 18 consecutive starts
during that span of 236 era that
includes so far this season all 2-0 with
a 150. here comes the introduction of
the return of fernando tatis jr welcome
back number 23.
bueller gets some swing into the cutter
a pitch that he's not used much over the
first couple starts
oh he has thrown predominantly
fastballs before seymour and as he
brings the cutter back in especially a
higher and higher ratio of them i think
we're going to see more of this with
percentage go up it's about half the
rate it was last year
bringing the ground ball up the middle
field to behind the bag by seeger who
then steps on second
fires to first and the inning is over no
runs one hit one left they're at the
corners with two down jerks in pro
profile at first manny machado at third
luis campusano at the plate for the
first time against walker bueller swings
at the first pitch and lines it into
right field for a base hit the padres
have a one-nothing lead betts has
bobbled it and that's going to allow
profar to go second to third one to
nothing san diego
pepusano with a big opposite field base
head well what do you do when you face a
guy like walker bueller i'll tell you
what you do you look for the number one
you get it first pitch you jump on it
you avoid the cutter two outs and that
takes us to corey seeger
seeger to left and
diving to make the catch is pro farm
laying it out in left field jericho
profile
outstanding a one two three third inning
for ryan weathers with a big assist to
his left fielder
fifth inning luke raleigh
hits one hard deep right center luke
really ties the game
with his first career big league home
run
trying to hold back the smile
let it loose luke you've got a big
league home run
he's big he's strong and he just proved
it well remember this the rest of his
life
he got it all
comes fernando struck out swinging in
the first in his return to the padres
starting lineup in activity after the
10-day il stint
in the air to center field taylor going
back and mendez left the building
fernando tatis jr returns to the padres
lineup and lifts it out of the yard
2-1 padres
this man is a star loves the bright
lights loves the big stage he gets a
fastball up and he cooks this ball
to dead central welcome back nando
and there's a fly ball a right center
field that one is deep and going back to
the wall and leaping and making the
catch as mookie bets for the second out
of the inning cronenworth narrowly
missing going back to back
not quite enough
in san diego
they're at the corners for la with two
down and chris taylor coming up
ground ball diving stop tatis goes to
second to throws wild
the game is tied
muncie's given the wave he heads for the
plate the dodgers take the lead
with a game time base hit tatisse with a
throw that opens the door for the go
ahead
run mckinstry chases it kicks away
and the dodgers add another he's going
to reach and taylor's going to score
a wild pitch on strike three and it's
4-2
with the swing just make sure you reach
taylor scores easily
jim in second grisham at first one out
chopped to third could be two
second for one
it'll get away run score coming in from
third is kim and it's a one-run game
he just rushes this knowing tatis is
coming down that line quick and throws
it away kim is able to come all the way
around to score madrid within one the
veteran pomerantz and the rookie
mckinstry
mckinsey inks aligner towards the right
field corner myers won't get there
it's off the wall here comes will smith
cronin worst throw to the plate is not
in time and an rbi double for zach
mckinstry
so mckenzie might have given him one
with the throwing there but he gets
someone here mckinstry is at second and
it is five to three georgetown profile
i've three dodgers in the bottom of the
eighth inning machado at third base
meyers at first base
profile lines it to left that'll get
into the corner
scoring as machado
meyers is going to try and score all the
way from first and he will it's tied at
five
clutch simply clutch for jericho profile
as he gets his teammate riled up as the
dodgers trying to take a lead in the top
half of the ninth inning
turner basement left center profile
grabs it betts headed for the plate
he'll throw in the second justin turner
comes through
and the dodgers lead six five in the
nine
tatties who's homer tonight the payoff
[Applause]
19th pitch
high and away ball four i think manny
did something to himself during that a b
the trainer is gonna join him three for
nine in his career against janssen
on the ground
and right field mcconnell scores six to
six eric hoesberg ties this game
6-6 in the bottom of the 10th inning
mateo gets hit with a first pitch
like he hasn't been hit enough lately
there we go they're gonna talk and now
we're gonna fight an epic battle tonight
of two heavyweights and a discussion
starts
after matteo was hit santana said
something and the bench is empty now the
bullpen is joining the party already
headed back to their respective benches
little carryover from last season shook
up the bottle right there and popped the
top dodgers looking for their first
extra innings run
they missed their fourth try seeger gets
into a ball way back there it's gone
first pitch of the 12th the two-run shot
from corey seeger dodgers eight padres
six
jake croninworth who is a two-way player
in the race system he's all big ten
closer of michigan is on to make his
major league debut as a pitcher
really grounds on to first
osmer feeds cronin worth his late
covering and it's 10-6
and now moscow is out there making the
catch
and a ball
slap to the left sacrifice fly makes it
11-6 that's david price who hit for
himself
and just got himself an rbi
[Applause]
[Music]
that will do it
what a rollercoaster ride game of the
year over the first couple weeks of the
season
in 12 innings the dodgers 11 the padres
6.